[Music]
it's brevity
stephen works with such certainty he's
really like a
one-man army because he edits his own
stuff he's shooting it and he's editing
it
an accurate reputation for being very
efficient
he would shoot it fast he will get you
home early
detailed genius once he hires someone
he's like
i'm trusting you to do the job i hired
you for
he's almost edited it in his mind
already stephen just kind of knows what
he wants and he comes in and he's like
this is all i need you guys give that to
me and then boom we move on
you trust him when he goes like hey i
got it and you go like are you sure and
he goes yeah i got it
shoots what he needs like i mean to
almost
to a point where as a filmmaker it kind
of made me anxious
to be quite honest when i was like you
might need a wide of this he's like no i
don't
i mean he's not just directing the movie
from
an objective perspective he's involved
he knows when he got
it and then we can move on it's not a
lot of
repeating the same thing over and over
you know and if something doesn't work
he has a new
strategy immediately a very light
camera sticking it in glove boxes of old
cars and under tables and
wherever it needed to be so we could
move very quickly and get a lot done in
very few takes
is just a testament to how confident he
is as a filmmaker
it doesn't feel like you're trapped
within kind of
the cam where the camera is it but it's
still very
quick making a period film on location
during a pandemic was a a tall order
and um when you have somebody like
stephen at the helm
it it makes all of those worries
kind of dissipate there wasn't like a
lot of talking on set there wasn't like
a ton of direction it was just sort of
you can kind of like read him
because he's right there behind the
camera it's not just the dp
he's actually camera upping the whole
entire
film very short days and then he would
spend the second half of that day
epping the moon so
by the time i left he showed me a really
good chunk of the movie
already cut together so i already had a
sense of what we were doing
it just very much felt like we were in
in very good hands
not what you were wearing but why you
are wearing it
you know those kinds of things he's
really working it out you know he's not
just like oh yeah
this is what i know he grinds and uh and
that's really interesting
it takes a minute before you can trust
that that you really have done
what you needed to do and that he really
knows but then you see the end product
you're like oh yeah i guess he really
didn't know
he really knows how to do it all the
result is
a film that's exciting very cool
stylized
and socially relevant